he ran hey you review video games yeah
when you're not handing them off to Mike
Maharis yeah yeah this week you're
reviewing or have reviewed a game called
I am set Sunna which is a game I was
calling I am Satsuma so as Lucy James
apparently do you notice that this
Satsuma called something else here
Satsuma isn't is a fruit I think it's a
large orange and from right so pump
containing okay I think maybe Mandarin
might be the word that's also used for
since it was I don't know it's something
there anyway you were not reviewing a
game about a small delicious fruit
you're in fact reviewing a game which
was interesting but this is Square
Enix's studio they set up to make Square
Enix ass games right I'm gonna say no
okay Square Enix doesn't make games like
this really anymore right so they're
making squaresoft like games right okay
classic JRPGs in the sort of Chrono
Trigger yeah any fantasy I might dial
that back a little bit because if you
think about it Chrono Trigger is the
first real Square Enix game right cuz it
was a collaboration between the best of
Final Fantasy devs and the best of
Dragon Quest oh so this is before screen
expose the thing but so maybe in some
sense you're right there's like the
progenitor okay technicality I get away
on it yeah so this is they're making
games in that sort of classic sense in
the way that like lots of their other
franchises have evolved and there's just
the natural way of things and so what I
would sort of got me review what did I
get seven oh seven nine ten I uncaged
buy you can get the review right now a
video review up as well on the site on
YouTube and what I got from it is that
it's it's quite derivative of sort of
square games is that to its benefit or
not in a lot of ways is to its benefit
because the source material is pretty
strong the things that it's pulling from
are great things to reference and the
only time it becomes an issue is I
suppose when those references as someone
who played games like Chrono Trigger and
the other RPGs that were coming out
around that time you just you recognize
it and it just takes you out of that
like the moment of the game and it's
distracting one and then it sort of it
makes you feel cynical because you're
like this is just a paint-by-numbers
kind of thing
it's not totally one-to-one but there
are so many elements that are like yeah
I've seen this before
but at the same time like it comes
together for a game that is largely
really enjoyable and yes makes me feel
nostalgic in a good way as well yeah how
does the combat work is it in this sort
of final classic Final Fantasy 7 worked
Chrono Trigger II it's definitely it's
almost exactly like Chrono Trigger
essentially there are no random
encounters you see enemies on all right
on the field you bump into them everyone
kind of like hops into position you can
avoid him if you want you can avoid them
if you want like if they are looking one
way or another you can sneak behind them
so yeah it's it's turn-based although
you can play in active mode or weight
mode active mode lets the turn meter
keep charging even when you're making a
decision will code lets you take your
time and think a little bit more rather
than having to like make a decision
before wasting learn can you choose to
swap at can you start the game on weight
mode and go into engine mode you can
swap at any time okay let's go yeah you
can get used to it yeah and many other
cool things is that characters can
combine skills so they may have one
character may have a heel attack another
one may have like a whirlwind attack
kind of thing and you can if they're in
your party and they both have those
skills equipped you can combine them and
like heal your whole party with one big
world work rather than just one person
and that applies to offensive stuff as
well so there's a lot of death to
explore in terms of building your party
and fitting out individual characters
and then fitting out a team with those
disparate parts and how they work
together excellent
what type of like how many characters
are we talking about here I'm guessing
you're going into the field and meeting
people and basing them to your party and
stuff yeah I want to say it's like six
or seven okay I don't have an exact
number it's top my head right half dozen
not a crazy amount right not a super
long game with either no about 20 hours
JRPG anyway I mean 20 hours is pretty
good right yeah so that the 20 hour
thing is interesting because it does
sort of like keep the pace up which is
good but there are certain things that
feel like they're worth further
examination like a character who has a
really big secret these kind of reveals
a tune he's like let's just keep this
between ourselves but but wait there's
so much to talk about like I want to
know more I want to know this and that
and it honestly never really has a
resolution one that's satisfying anyway
and they're even characters like there's
a guy with a scythe who is he's like a
direct like
creation of Magus from chrono triggers
guy with a scythe who's kind of you know
he's evil but he doesn't really get the
same development as Magnus like you
don't get to to understand him in his
motivations he kind of just appears and
is like the perfect or a bad guy right
but you know a lot of the character is
what makes the story interesting is the
characters themselves bringing emotional
baggage to the table they don't
necessarily develop it which is too bad
but they all have something about them
that is like kind of tragic makes you
sympathize with them a little bit
questions coming from the chat yeah
genius didn't start asking at what
console is this for would you play it
off I'll put it on PlayStation 4 it's
also coming to steam in North America
and Europe cool Japan got a Vita version
we are not getting that oh really
yeah okay unfortunately it's a shame but
you can play it by ear mode play if you
want god I wonder why that seems to
seems like exotic game that I actually
would pick up on it's made in unity
check a box yeah right that's already
done they just didn't I don't know
that's bizarre it is strange like why
they would just omit that opportunity to
make money it makes me worried that Sony
aren't even pushing
I mean it's Square Enix as well you
think that would be something they'd be
like look well sorry you act just like
put this ad on the video it makes me
think that Sony don't give a [ __ ] about
the imperfect segi when I see things
about oh I don't know sorry Jake we're
gonna say oh I was sorry would you think
of the presentation no cuz I came by
your desk and you were playing and I was
like oh it looks beautiful you're like
yeah but you didn't seem too excited and
then I was like alright well I thought
it looks beautiful and I started editing
the review and I noticed that the
environments look really similar yeah
like they're not 99% of the environments
are winter land
right right snowy forest snowy towns no
we Fields occasionally you go into these
sort of like maybe it's another
dimension it's just some sort of weird
place that's dark and you can't really
see much and they're floating things he
was the rules of nature don't lie yeah
like I actually really liked the art and
there are some scenes where the lighting
and the composition like framing the
scene work really well together and I
think okay someone behind this took the
time to make sure that this was a
special moment but there are a lot of a
lot of things that do just look kind of
bland right unfortunately but but by and
large I think maybe I came around after
I played the game some more and I saw
more of those things that were
impressive so I think it's a decent
looking game especially one that
like it's a 3d game that's trying to
mimic what a 2d game used to do and I
think it does that pretty well yeah cool
oh yeah today sure I forget I just
remember embargoes today yeah I'm
curious like how do you feel about this
game because I know that you like
Japanese RPGs is this something that's
been on your radar
are you interested it has been on my
radar it because I thought it looked
beautiful to be honest but then after
editing the review I'm not quite as
excited as I was before I think just
because what I did edit it looked a lot
of like the same stuff and like even the
dungeon stuff that you did give me just
felt very like it just felt kind of out
of place but I mean I'll still probably
give it a try and I think and everyone's
been talking about how great the music
is - I don't know you thought of that
but that's kind of something I do wanna
that's a yeah that's a weird thing for
me I did really like the music it's all
piano right which over time it kind of
drags you down a little bit like I love
listening to piano arrangements of
classic game soundtracks it's a
wonderful instrument but for an entire
game to be just one instrument is a bit
much the thing that really got me was
some of the songs are so clearly riffing
on a trigger music really where it's
like the same chord progression just a
different tempo order yeah and like
that's this kind of thing where I'm like
this is [ __ ] lazy right I I cannot
respect I can say yeah it's beautiful
but I don't respect that song it's like
the artistry behind it's a difficult
line to sort of walk right to be like
referential to the past what I'm having
it up to my you think it kind of crosses
over it's a little bit too - absolutely
yeah I mean this this game is littered
with things that if you've been playing
Japanese RPGs for years you will say
okay that is that is frog from Chrono
Trigger that is our on from Final
Fantasy 10 right this is the plot from
Final Fantasy 10 that's printed triggers
battle system the random events from the
saga frontier games that have heard
during battle all these things just you
know kind of coalesce into a thing that
that's just super referential yeah a few
times it does stand out though I did
feel like the game has an identity of
its own I would just love to see them
take all this knowledge and expertise
making it a classic RPG mmm but doing
something totally original with it not
just trying to say hey guys fans I know
what you like you've been asking for her
for years he
it is like stop complaining like okay
but you have to take it the next step
yeah it can't just be that yeah I don't
think we're gonna be talking about this
game in 20 years right if we talk about
credit rigor now but a fun game to play
yes I think people should play it I mean
I is an endorsement in my book it's good
out of 10 not really seven out of ten
and that's the way I like to think about
it yeah yeah good stuff out today on a
PlayStation 4 I guess no Vita version
for us right yeah the Steam version
should be out today okay steam as well
yeah pick it up there if you want at
$39.99 as I checked might be a bit
cheaper on C my mom's day that's all
that happens go check it out thank you
so much Peter yeah
preciate